ええ。
quantum circuitはビジネスにおける価値の単位になります
qubitは情報の単位ですが
circuitは計算の単位です
では、quantum circuitとは何かを理解していきましょう
その構造を見ていきます
これがquantum circuitの見た目です
いくつかの要素で構成されており、qubitは
これらの水平線で表されています。この例では
4つのqubitを持つcircuitが
ここに示されています。gateは
qubitを制御する方法で
gateは左から右に読みます
single qubit gateは
single qubit gateまたはmulti qubit gateになります
そこにcontrolled gateが見えます
2つのqubitの間に線があるものがそれです
そこでエンタングル操作が行われます
最後に測定と古典的な出力があります
重要なのは、circuitを何度も実行するということです
shotsという概念で結果を得るために
shotカウンターとは、結果を得るために
計算を繰り返す回数のことです
では
どのように見えるのでしょうか
2 qubit circuitがどのようなものか見てみましょう
先ほどの図は位相変化を導入したものでしたね
その回転を行うZ操作を先ほど示しました
それにより干渉操作が可能になります
では古典的なcircuitと
quantum circuitを比較してみましょう。古典的なcircuitでは
青い月は見えません
回転はなく、すべてがピンクです
単一の状態だけがあります
これらのgateで見られるのはそういった状態です
しかし実際にquantum circuitを実装すると
どれほど対照的に見えるかに注目してください
これらは量子コンピューターで実際に実行するcircuitです
皆さんも試すことができます
私たちが作成するcircuitは
gateの組み合わせによって
完全な複素振幅を生成します
先ほどご紹介した
図がそれです。なぜ重要かというと
qubit間にこうした複雑な関係を
位相という観点で生成できるからです
エンタングルメントと測定という行為を通じて
この膨大な量の計算を
内部で行い、それを
重要な答えへと収束させることができます
こうして最終的に
答えにたどり着きます。並べて見ると、視覚的にも
古典的なcircuitでは決して活用できない
広大な計算空間があることがわかります
quantum circuitはその空間を活用できます
これがこの大きな状態空間にアクセスできる
豊かさの直感を与えてくれます。
そして素晴らしいのは
異なるクラスのcircuitを持てることです
それぞれ異なる機能を持ちます
例えばこれは
金融リスクをモデル化するために設計されたcircuitです
これは
検索と最適化問題に使用されるcircuitの例です
そしてこれは分子を
シミュレートするために使われるcircuitの例です。重要な
ポイントは、異なるアプリケーションに対して
異なるcircuitを設計できるということです
設計したcircuitはソフトウェアとして
取り込まれ、保存されます
私たちの場合はQiskitに保存します
これは量子コンピューティング向けのオープンソース開発キットです
これは最も広く使われている
量子コンピューティングのソフトウェアフレームワークの一つです
circuitのライブラリを構築することも想像できます
そのライブラリは古典的なプログラムに組み込まれ
古典的なプログラミングの長所と
量子コンピューティングのパワーを組み合わせます